[Music]
what's up guys
jared again spider-man into the
spider-verse burst into theaters in 2018
and was immediately met with critical
acclaim
eventually crescendoing into an oscar
win for best animated film
it's a rare film to surpass 90 approval
ratings amongst both critics
and audiences on rotten tomatoes and
quickly established itself as a fan
favorite importantly based on
wisecrack's unscientific and
anecdotal evidence the film was also an
incredible conversion machine
turning decidedly non-comic book lovers
into spidey stands in just under two
hours
so what makes this movie so intoxicating
i mean besides the obvious magnetism of
nicholas cage's acting sometimes i let
matches burn down to my fingertips just
to feel something anything
oh okay but seriously is it the
charismatic relatable
non-shoelace tying miles is it the
trippy visual aesthetic
spider-ham or is there something deeper
going on here
and does it have anything to do with
charles dickens let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on spider-man
into the spider-verse deep or dumb and
as always
spoilers ahead alright let's dive into a
recap
meet miles morales a brooklyn kid who
hates his pretentious new boarding
school visions academy
while graffitiing a subway service
tunnel with his cool uncle aaron
miles gets bitten by a radioactive
spider and
well you know what happens trying to
figure out why his hands are so sticky
miles returns to the scene where he
stumbles upon spider-man trying to stop
kingpin from using a deadly particle
collider to access another dimension
the experiment gets cut short and
spider-man gives miles a thumb drive
to override the collider before getting
killed by kingpin
still green at the whole spider-manning
thing miles swiftly destroys the drive
by accident
miles finds out that kingpin's particle
collider did partially succeed
at least in summoning a bunch of other
spider persons into his dimension
among them the older dad bodied peter b
parker
spider gwen spider penny spider ham and
spider academy award winner nicholas
cage
they team up to defeat kingpin and
return to their dimensions
miles becomes his dimension's new
friendly neighborhood spider-man
the end so is spider-verse deep or just
an emotionally engaging
heartwarming feast for the eyes let's
review the evidence argument 1
miles quantum arc the film's first
suspected reservoir of depth rests in
the journey of newly anointed spider-man
miles
if we weren't sure what the central
theme of miles arc is
the movie pretty blatantly telegraphs it
right up top when he and his dad discuss
his life
we all make choices in life it doesn't
feel like i have a choice you don't
peter parker echoes this sentiment once
miles has been bitten
telling him that becoming spider-man
ain't optional
i don't think you have a choice kiddo
but what's exceptionally clever about
the film's exploration of choice
is the way it's reinforced through
recurring references to quantum theory
and quantum mechanics
scientific concepts central to the plot
in an early scene miles science class
watches a video about the topic
in it a civilian clothe doc ock explains
our universe is in fact one of many
parallel universes happening at the
exact same time
here she outlines the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which holds that there are many parallel
universes existing in the same space and
time as our own
including a tragic dimension in which i
shaved my beard and woody was dog napped
by pirates
anyway doc goes on to say that every
choice that we make
would create countless other
possibilities
[Music]
here the film invokes an aspect of
quantum mechanics the idea that every
opportunity yields multiple
possibilities which ripple out
eventually creating countless more
possibilities although relevant to
miles's outer conflict
having to save the multiverse with his
pals it also mirrors
miles as inner conflict confronting the
fact that every choice is a leap of
faith down a diverging path
one that has ripple effects we see this
early on through the motif of miles
shoelaces
it starts with miles's dad telling him
tie your shoes please
then when a random student says the same
he replies hey yeah
his shoe's inside yeah i'm aware it's a
choice
even spider-man soon joins the chorus
you know your shoes aren't tied
still miles continues to rock the untied
look
fittingly this choice has a consequence
he trips over his laces and breaks the
thumb drive he needed to disable the
accelerator
here we see the power of choice and the
consequences of one's choices
literalized
the theme of choice and diverging paths
is reinforced by contrasting versions of
peter parker
the first one has lived up to his
responsibilities to protect new york
and died a hero as a result his foil
peter b
parker the type b of the two is the
less than perfect spider-man who chose
to alienate his wife
fall out of shape and spend a lot of
time crying in the bathtub
instead of saving the city their shared
name and essential attributes suggest
that they could have gone down similar
paths but the ripple effects of choice
and the infinite possibilities presented
by those choices
led them to become very different spider
dudes a similar dichotomy exists in the
contrast between miles as dad and uncle
aaron
each offering a unique path for miles
future miles exist in a flux between his
lawful dad
and his cool uncle aaron who likes to
indulge in some light artistic vandalism
early on aaron tells miles that his dad
also used to be a rule-breaking punk
before he made the choice to straighten
out and become a very rule abiding cop
oh my gosh don't cops run red lights
well yeah some do
but uh not your dad in contrast uncle
aaron's rebellious streak has led him
down a drastically different path
one which involves working for kingpin
killing people
and generally being a not great guy in
his final moments
uncle aaron reflects on the gravity of
his mistakes
i want you to look up to me
i'll let you down man i'll let you down
this functions as an interesting
reversal of the uncle ben story
in which spider-man lets a robber go
only to find out that this very robber
shot and killed his beloved uncle in
that narrative he blames himself for
making the wrong choice
in contrast this time its uncle aaron
not miles who blames himself for the
series of choices that led him to die in
an alleyway and leave his nephew uncles
just as the death of uncle ben taught
peter parker that he has to use his
powers and use them
responsibly the death of uncle aaron
teaches miles
that his choices can easily lead him
down a regrettable path
and that he must take responsibility for
those choices the dire mistake of not
taking responsibility for your choices
is also embodied in kingpin
who can't live with himself for driving
his family away such that they
literally drove away and got into a car
crash
and died the ripple effects of his
actions have left him all alone
rather than accepting responsibility he
tries to reverse fate by summoning his
family from another dimension
so we see several characters accepting
varying levels of responsibility for
their choices
as well as the ripple effects and
diverging paths that come with those
choices
the central question of the film becomes
what kind of person and specifically
what kind of spider guy
will miles become in the universe of
this film this calls to mind another
aspect of quantum mechanics
the copenhagen interpretation which a
few physicists dreamt up in the 1920s
the theory postulates that an object can
and does exist
in all possible states for instance are
photons particles
or waves well sometimes they act like
particles and
sometimes they act like waves quantum
mechanics uses the term
superposition to refer to multiple
possible states existing at once
say a wave or a particle or an alive cat
or a dead cat
metaphorically miles exists in a kind of
indeterminate superposition between two
extremes
he exists in both the state of becoming
like his criminal uncle aaron
or like his honorable cop father but
here's the thing about superpositions
when somebody observes the object in
question its superposition
collapses meaning that the object is
forced to choose a probability
that is become either a wave or a
particle in the film it's not literal
observation that forces miles to choose
which state to exist in
although he certainly is being observed
by his fellow spider people
rather it's the immense pressure of the
task at hand so
what decision is he going to make well
at the beginning of the film we see him
choosing to resist responsibility
he doesn't want to take advantage of
getting into a prestigious school
and even chooses to get every question
on his true false test
wrong so it's not surprising that when
he's first bitten
he resists and actively does not want to
take on the mantle of spider-man
you're like me i don't want to be when
he watches peter parker fighting off
multiple bad guys he knows he should
help but realizes
who my kid and i should not do that here
he's choosing
passivity rather than making an active
decision regardless
miles learns that his choices have
ripple effects peter parker dies
though it's not implied he blames
himself for parker's death he does blame
himself for not doing anything to try to
stop it
as indicated the next time he's faced
with a similar situation
i can't sit there and just let
spider-man die without doing anything
about it i'm not doing that again
we start seeing miles make active
choices like choosing to help peter b
parker steal trade secrets we also see
miles taking responsibility for the
promises he's made
look i made a promise so i have to keep
it
this underscores the way the theme of
choice is used as a new take
on the cliche spider-man theme of with
great power
come on great dare finish that sentence
don't do it
i'm sick of it in the first two thirds
of the film we watch miles accept his
new identity and express
desire to keep the promises he made to
peter parker and save the glitching
spider people
but we start to realize that miles's
choice to embrace being spider-man won't
be enough
as he can't control his finicky powers
however in the next pivotal scene
miles asks peter b parker when will i
know i'm ready you won't
it's a leap of faith here the film
posits a so-called
leap of faith or the choice to take a
chance and embrace the scary unknown
which here means diving into a dangerous
situation without knowing if you're
ready
miles is able to take this leap after an
encouraging monologue from his father
who says a lot of adorable daddish stuff
like i see this
this spark in you it's amazing it's why
i push you but
it's yours whatever you choose to do
with it you'll be great
the message seems to be that the choice
to believe in oneself
is ultimately the most important choice
of all as soon as miles is able to do
that
he goes from sticky fingers to smooth
operator
well at least when it comes to
spider-man he could still use some work
in the romance department
friends friends
it's also worth noting that peter b
parker similarly undergoes a leap of
faith in oneself when he returns to his
own dimension
and rather than bemoaning his fate
attempts to fix it
he reconciles with mj presumably in the
hopes of finally making his dad bod
dad certified even though he doesn't
know if he's ready to change diapers
so there you have it a film with truly
smart screenwriting that uses quantum
theory thematically
to mirror the main character's larger
emotional arc
smart yes but deep like deep dish pizza
deep like wait a second what's the deal
with this
argument 2 is great expectations a great
deep
or dumb reference charles dickens novel
great expectations becomes a recurring
reference in the film
miles english class is reading the book
he gets assigned to write an essay on it
after deliberately failing a test
and even riffs on the book's title in
his graffiti art the recurring presence
of this novel
on its face seems to imply that miles
has the potential to go from average
brooklyn kid
to truly dope superhero that he will
literally go from having
no expectations to living up to majorly
great expectations
after his uncle dies miles throws the
notebook with his great expectations
graffiti art out of the window
as if giving up on the task before him
in direct rebuttal
peter b parker throws the notebook right
back at him as if
insisting that he live up to the great
spider-man name
so surface level reference or deep
thematic connection
it appears to just be a surface level
nod to dickens novel as it doesn't
really speak to what the book is about
importantly it seems to ignore the fact
that dickens novel deals heavily in
irony and satire
and his protagonist pip is something of
a punchline
a blacksmith's nephew an apprentice pip
is obsessed with improving his status
and becoming more sophisticated
so he can win over his truly unpleasant
love interest estella
while miles is special in spite of his
initial desire to just be normal
and generally not live up to his
potential pip believes that he is
special and entitled to more than his
humble lot in life
and thus spends the book attempting to
realize the great expectations he has
for himself
the entire story is told from the point
of view of an older pip who has since
learned that his expectations were
baloney
in contrast miles learns over the course
of the film that his expectations for
himself need to be
higher you could read them as foils to
one another but we don't really see how
that contrast deepens the meaning
or adds anything much of value to the
film so we're going to say that in this
interpretation
the film is deep with a debatably kinda
dumb literary reference
argument three the spiderverse as eye
candy
there's one more layer to this film that
we'd be dumb not to mention its visuals
from a purely aesthetic perspective this
film is absolutely revolutionary
for context basically since 1995 when
pixar released the first cgi animated
feature toy story
the lamp loving studio has set the
standard for what modern animation
should look like
you'd recognize that aesthetic anywhere
shiny surfaces
clean lines highly realistic imagery now
we love pixar as much as the next
emotionally stunted millennial but we'd
argue that spider-verse is so
visually stunning because it blatantly
refuses to conform to the pixar look
instead the film fully embraces the
comic book aesthetic
becoming increasingly more comic
book-like as miles transforms into
spider-man
this is even clearer from the opening
moments which show the sony logo fading
into ben day dots
bend a dots are those tiny circles you
see in some comic books
usually in the colors of cyan magenta
yellow or black
they were initially used by comic book
illustrators in the early to mid 1900s
to create a sense of depth and tonal
range on the cheap
printing a bunch of tiny dots was less
expensive than printing large swaths of
solid color
comic book artists today will often use
ben day dots to indicate a flashback
or a vocamore retro aesthetic the
geniuses behind spiderverse's animation
employ ben day dots throughout the film
particularly during moments of emotional
intensity
in this way they mimic the aesthetic
that accompanied some of the earliest
spider-man comics in the 60s through
sheer inventiveness it debatedly does
more to evoke the original spider-man
experience
than any other rendition before it other
comic book visual effects
also work their way into the film from
the written sound effects
to actual paneling to the spidey sense
by incorporating so many hallmark
qualities of comic books
the film inherently defends the
oft-maligned medium
at the same time the film also visually
pays homage to another frequently
derided medium
street art first miles literally creates
eye-popping street art and we watch the
long laborious process that entails then
the shapes and colors of miles art
return with a vengeance later on when
the super collider is turned on
also he spray paints his spidey suits
giving it a graffitied aesthetic
some of the film's most visually
masterful moments occur when it's
directly evoking street art so
that's pretty cool too the film elevates
both the street art and comic book
aesthetic making a compelling argument
for the artistic merits of both
for all these reasons we're inclined to
see spider-man into the spider-verse as
a pretty deep film
couching miles's arc in quantum theory
is so sharp
and the visuals are on point the great
expectations thing
eh it can't ruin this fun and
heartwarming film
but what do you guys think is there
indeed more to the miles morales story
than meets the eye
or is our peter tingle way off track
[Music]
you